Expect to see
something different,
something scary, something
fun, and something heartfelt.
[EERIE SCREAMING]
"Werewolf by Night" is a story
where a bunch of characters
are coming together for
a very frightening time.
We're going to introduce
you to Jack and Elsa,
and see what dangerous
adventures they get up
to over one night trapped
with a secret cabal
of monster hunters.
It's kind of the first
real full exploration into
this supernatural universe.
At Disney+ we
have the opportunity
to tell stories of
different levels,
and so this is our first
special presentation.
It's a little bit under
an hour, because it's
given you a taste--
maybe an appetizer--
of the monster side of the MCU.
We went and we filmed it
completely in black and white.
And I think that's going to
be a different experience
for everyone.
LAURA DONNELLY:
It is a throwback
to the '30s and '40s
horror movies that I loved
whenever I was growing up.
It's really unique.
What we want to do is create
an experience for somebody
that years from now
they can go, "You
know what scared me as a kid?
This-- when I watched this.
And I never forgot it."
I hope that they maybe
might go back and explore some
of those old horror movies
as well, some of those ones
that I loved
whenever I was a kid.
I hope that audiences get
to enjoy the fun, the scares,
the excitement, but also fall
in love with these characters
of Jack and Elsa, and see
where they go on their journey,
and maybe what surprising
end they come to.
If I were to have to turn into
an animal under a full moon,
it would be some cross between
probably an ape and a wolf,
I guess.
I think I'd be a bat.
A bat-- they're
a little scary.
They're also a little cute.
"Werewolf by Night" is scary
vintage horror with a heart.
A love letter to every movie
I grew up watching as a kid.
"Werewolf by Night"
is the tale
you've been waiting for it
to bring you into the monster
side of the MCU.
LAURA DONNELLY: Don't
miss "Werewolf by Night"
now streaming on Disney+.
[EERIE SCREAMING]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]